I seen this series over here I'm not a
thing not a GP but it is a very very
famous series it's called the harmonic
series its famous because it looks when
you look at the end of town right it
looks like it's vanishing off 20 that in
turn right as a depression figure well
it is it doesn't look like it is he is
okay so you might tend to think well
therefore made it be a what we call a
convergent series like the gps with our
is less than 1 or greater than negative
1 right it's getting smaller and smaller
and smaller so is it like that um is it
like that really sad frog who jumps
halfway and then John's halfway halfway
driveways and you know it never actually
gets there right is it a we call this a
convergent series or is it a series more
wine 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8 which
doesn't converge to anything it just
blows on right yeah this looks like it
would be a convention series but there's
a famous proof then you can go we're
video for it if you want for the fact
that is not convergent at all and when
you have a look at what this some
inequality is establishing its always
less than the square root of n but
because it is approaching infinity this
thing has no upper limit like it's like
the log curve the locker slows down
forever but it never gets to zero in
fact this is a very very closely between
this and the long term so anyway just an
interesting piece of trivia let's have a
look at where I picked up I've just
begun my regular old proof by induction
okay I haven't gone anywhere near parte
yet because well at the beginning of a
proof by induction there's no need to
bring in fancy deductive logic you test
your first case it's close but it works
okay I should have said that that's
less than or equal to the way outside so
therefore you establish your best case
you make your assumption and then you
get your k plus one case ready now do
you remember how I showed you when
you've got inner qualities such as this
one of the ways you're going to approach
this is to rework your assumption and
rework your proof step such you have a
zero on the left hand side okay and the
reason why we like to do that is because
it's really good to prove that something
is completely positive or completely
negative today now I'm going to do
something much the same way but i'm just
going to format it slightly differently
so here's what I'm going to write if I
were to do what I was suggesting and
I'll bring this over to the left hand
side and have a 0 over there on the
ground and what I'm having a left is 1
plus a half percent the [ __ ] life part
plus plus plus take away root k plus 1
that's what my left hand side would be
and then what I want for that is to be
negative so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say consider and then I'm going
to start with what that left hand side
would be okay so that's all of this one
haha I said bird the dot
minus that and my goal we're on hearing
is I want this thing to be less than
zero I want it to be negative so just
keep that in your head yeah oh yeah
we've got my wife special videos so let
me just put a rental note for myself
that this time here I want this negative
ok so now I've got my ball / set up and
now it's just a matter of getting so
when I look at this I see ok this is a
proof by induction because this is a
series i can see that the assumptions
that the inductive hypothesis is right
there in my in the line that I've just
written right can you see where it is
where is it it's the first how many
times it's the first caters right
because there's the first term second
term third term that's the cave turn
right there like so ok now what I know
from the assumption is that all that
stuff is less than Rick a pen so here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to say if
ice point in place of that a recce right
instead of all that stuff plus one on k
plus 1 minus one like so well my
assumption says that this red piece
should be smaller than this green piece
do you agree with that ok so can you see
if red is more than green register all
the green and everything else is the
same then this whole thing should be
less than that do you agree with that
that's what I can say from my assumption
ok if you like I'm sort of taking the
assumption and I'll just added these
things to it if you see that so the
Assumption had the inequality facing in
that direction and then I just added
some equal things to both sides so the
inner quality is preserved so far so
good I better say where I got that from
so now I think about that what I've got
over there and because I want this to be
negative think about how can I muck
around with this in order to show that
it is going to be well less than zero
that's where I'm headed okay